so in China a 10 year old boy who's  being disciplined by his grandma ends up  fighting back he puts his grandma  headline you always hit me why you  always hit me she's picked up a slipper  and just like hitting him  and then slowly it just becomes oh no he  chokes her to death no she should have  stopped hitting him she did like  literally snapped blacked out maybe she  was abusing him he would think he was  gonna kill her though I think it's wrong  that he did that but at the same time  it's like dude that's her karma for like  treating somebody this way too damn you  ruthless dog no because it always come  back it always comes back to you in some  way it may it would suck that it was the  boy that did it to her yin yang dude I  don't know I